what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
um this is morning coffee thoughts part
two so
I want to talk about some stuff that
I've been struggling with the last
couple of months
um
now
if you hear snoring that's my dog when I
first started the channel I actually
don't remember a time
in my life that I was like happier
um I mean maybe a couple moments but in
general like
the this last summer I had so much fun
it was really stressful
um
oh my God it was so stressful oh my gosh
it was it was so stressful and I I
couldn't do it again but
it was really cool to be working on
something that I had like seen in my
head for so many years and like finally
get success on it so
um
yeah it was it like this summer was when
I saw a lot of growth on my channel
because I think it started in like May
of last year when it first started to
like really take off and like get a lot
of subscribers
um
and actually start making money and it
was just like a fun time and honestly I
started making money and I wasn't even
spending it on me like I was spending it
on other people like buying all this
stuff for the channel and like whatever
but
it was just like things were just like
moving and the weather was good and I
was in the shitty apartment but
um you know it was a really small
operation at that point like I had a
producer and someone to like help around
the apartment
um
and I don't know it was just like fun I
don't know
um
and I'd been home in May so I didn't
miss my family so much and they came to
see me in July so it was like
a mix but
in the last couple of months it's like
something switched
and I don't know what exactly switched
um I think it was like
all the girls like
the conflict just months over months
just started to like grow on me and I
think
the online hate it kind of just started
you know I just feel like I sort of
it's weird because I was hitting all
these accomplishments but
and what I've achieved in a year in in
all honesty is like amazing like who has
done this but I just started to kind of
like lose my confidence a bit and I was
just like getting worn out down and
really tired
um and so I went home I tried to take
some time off
um
but what I realized is that I really
really missed my family
and it was kind of like the first year
you really aren't gone that long when
you've moved away but it's like the
second year you just start to like
notice things like I'll realize oh [__]
I haven't talked to my brother in a
couple months
and it's kind of like when you're home
at some point like you'll see them
and it's it's weird because it's like
family is always the thing that you
don't really have to put that much
effort into like keeping those
relationships because you'll just see
them especially when you're home but
I've been in a whole nother country so
um I realized in the last like three to
six months my desire to go home and I
really want to start a family and I
really want to have kids and I really
want to do that but I want to do it in
America
um I just don't see myself like long
like I just don't think I could do 10
years in England
um and I kind of experience the life of
like flying back and forth constantly
and it was just hard like
um I just really missed
being home in all honesty and
when I go home I just feel like I'm like
another level of happy but the problem
is
I bought all this equipment and I have
all these people here and the people I
have here are literally phenomenal like
my producer I genuinely think is the
best in the whole space I you can't tell
me
any podcast that I think has a better
set than us
and
um I just got a new assistant and she's
phenomenal and I just I've made these
really good base here I have a base of
people that we can call on for the show
so even though we're kind of in a
recruiting like
hell hole case right now
um
at least I know that I have like a base
of people and I don't have to like start
over so it's kind of like you want to
move the business in a way
um because I'm really sick of flying
back and forth and I get a lot of really
good podcast opportunities but like for
example last time I was home I was
invited to go on Tim pool but
it was just like I felt like life was
just like wearing on me and I was just
like I gotta wait till the next time I'm
in the U.S because it's just too much
and
you know in the US you're just able to
like
we really haven't had a ton of big
guests on our show really like
we maybe had like three content four
five content creators in the UK but like
most of the interviews I've done I've
interviewed people in the US
um
like
so I realized this but now I'm in this
limbo where it's like okay in order to
go to the US I've figured out which
employees would want to go and the
majority would
um I have to figure out their visas um
I'd have to figure out what equipment we
can take back what we'd have to sell
um
I'd have to find a new place there
like there's just so much that I would
have to do and
I'm gonna do it because I want to go
home and that's my long-term plan but
it just makes it a lot more difficult
it's not like you can like tomorrow
go and leave you know
um
and it also makes dating a bit
interesting too because I'm here but I
want to go to the US
um so it's like
any guy that I would date would have to
be cool with going to the U.S at some
point
um
because it's just the flying just like
takes a toll on you and I didn't notice
so much oh my gosh Ellie my dog is Ellie
she having a nightmare with them
and I I didn't notice too much the first
year
um
and I'm really happy with the decision
like I've made to go to the US but it's
just
the path to getting there is a lot
and I don't know what's switched between
the summer and now because in the summer
I was really like happy here and
um
I do think that
success I've really seen a different
side of people sometimes when it comes
to like friendship and when it comes to
um
you really when you become successful
you really see who was there like for
the right reasons because
a lot of people kind of switch up when
you become successful and start to feel
like entitled and you know maybe that
one idea they had for a video
um
or something they said to you they'll
feel like
I don't know entitled to money you're
entitled to this or that and
um
I don't try to come out here and like
because sometimes
I don't mean to like complain too much
or anything but
I don't know I'm just like telling you
guys what's going on
and if you don't want to listen it's
okay like I don't I don't but see even
that I'm like I feel like I have to give
a disclaimer that I have a really good
life and I'm really happy overall as a
person
um but I just really like I want to go
home so bad but I feel like I'm like
stuck here
um
and
yeah
um
I don't know and then on top of that you
just start to get these crazy people
like
you guys already know if you saw my last
coffee thought about these crazy women
I have to order Uber soon for practice
let me see
I'm going to practice in a bit
the second thing I wanted to talk about
was
volleyball a lot of people ask like why
I went to the UK in the first place like
how did I end up here and the one thing
that maybe made me into a little bit
more of a modern woman because I was
kind of wondering
you know I have Traditional Values but
when it comes to like traditional skill
set there's a lot of things that I need
Improvement on and I was kind of
reflecting on my life I was like what
I dropped an earring okay what got me to
this point and I realized it was
volleyball
I didn't I was never really home for
dinner in all honesty um like family
dinner I just played Sports and I I
don't even want to make it it's hard I
don't want to make it sound like a bad
thing because I loved it oh my gosh I
loved it I could play for hours I just
had so much fun and
so it's like how do you learn to cook
when you're playing volleyball till 10
o'clock at night like I always I played
volleyball I played basketball I ran
track I did it in college I did in high
school
um I went to a private school that was
45 minutes away or was 30 minutes away
from my house and then my practice for
club was 45 minutes away from that so I
was just driving I was going everywhere
um and it taught me a lot of good
lessons but I realized like a lot of a
certain skills I really didn't learn
that like more traditional women did and
I'm actually really glad I found this
content and it's given me the
opportunity to like realize where you
know I've learned so many recipes last
year honestly
um
and cooking is so empowering too because
it's like you just start to feel better
and I didn't even realize that most days
I didn't even eat three meals like I
didn't even notice it I would just like
eat when I was hungry and I'd be
snacking and it was just
I still do I still need to work on it
but
I realized I was only thin because I
didn't even eat that much like I really
wasn't eating like full nutritious meals
um
and it was kind of all linked back to
I'm I'm cheap so I don't really like to
eat out too much but my inability to
cook and I was like why didn't I learn
to cook and that's what brought me to
England was I was working this sales job
and
um
yeah I took
um I quit it to work Beyond social media
and or to work in social media and my
plan was to go get a pro contract in
England so
um I quit the sales job in the summer
and then
my plan was three months later to go to
England and play volleyball and I wanted
to get a pro contract and I actually did
like a lot of things in life that I go
after I really do get because I work
really hard at it and
um
yeah I was offered a pro contract in the
fall
um
I turned it down because the YouTube
stuff like doesn't make sense
to play for like two grand a month with
free housing it might be even less than
that I don't even remember
um with free housing
with the type of money I'm making on
YouTube does that really make sense I
love it oh my gosh I love it but
I've noticed that while I love
volleyball so much A lot of times the
sport really does keep women single
because a lot of us don't really have
like the domestic skills that a lot of
other women have and
um we love the game so like so oh my
gosh I can't even I get goosebumps just
like talking about it because I love
playing but you know everything in life
comes at a cost and I just realized like
I could keep pursuing the pro thing but
if I want to have a family like what
does that look like and
I don't think volleyball is the most
conducive for a family like maybe you
know tournaments on the weekends but
so
it was kind of like I came here to do
that and this this YouTube thing just
blew up and I I thought it would get big
but I thought it would get like 100k big
not a freaking million in a year who the
hell could predict that that was my goal
I wrote my goal last year was a hundred
thousand Subs by the end of the year
um
so you know I thought
that was doable but what I realized is
like
I don't even want to say it's
necessarily a bad thing but
a lot of times like everything you love
comes at a cost and I've just always
been a passionate person that was what I
love to do I love to play
um
but I realized like this has to be my
last season for club because I just
don't have the freaking time for it
anymore
um
so
oh air table I was like I just got a
security alert but it was airtable okay
okay let's see what I know what that is
um
yeah but
I'm trying to think but that's what got
me to England
um and then I kind of I don't want to
say I got stuck here but I accidentally
stayed because
it was just easier like it was easier
than moving to America it was easier
than taking a pro contract in Germany or
Poland or whatever was going to pay me
to play I was like you know what I'm
just gonna go home or I'm just gonna
stay here because I have the recruiters
here I have the base here I have all
this stuff in hindsight maybe it would
have been easier
before this stuff got big big to like do
that in America but
you live and you learn do you guys feel
like there's a unique value add
from being in the UK or no it doesn't
matter I'm probably gonna go to America
anyway because of personal stuff but
I've also toyed around with the idea of
having like houses in different cities
but I just think
I really in the long run don't want to
be the one managing everything
um I really in the long run see myself
filling that role with someone else but
we need to increase the revenue in order
to do that
um
so
I don't know um let me know guys in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time